hello and welcome to the shehas I shade
we're in this video we're going to talk
about a human study into the biological
impacts of intermittent fasting and in
particular some of the protein changes
that were observed and so these results
were published in a paper that came out
at the start of this year with a very
long title intermittent fasting from
dawn to sunset for 30 consecutive days
is associated with anti-cancer
proteomics signature and up regulates
key regulatory proteins of glucose and
lipid metabolism circadian clock DNA
repair cytoskeleton remodeling immune
system and cognitive function and
healthy subjects but unlike the length
of that title this video will be short
and sweet and we'll just cover the key
points from this study in particular
that we'll just look at intermittent
fasting and then we'll look at the setup
of this study and what they examines
what they saw and then we'll talk about
some of the limitations and my own
thoughts for the study but firstly let's
look at what infamous and fasting
actually means so there are different
forms of intermittent fasting but
they're all united by the fact that
intermittent fasting is a strategy for
mill timing scheduling so there's quite
a bit of hype around intermittent
fasting because there are some studies
that show you that time restricted
feeding has benefits and that comes down
to the connection between timing and the
circadian clock or the skating rhythm
that I have spoken about fairness
channel which is the daily fluctuations
in selectivity and physiological
responses and so the connection between
intermittent fasting and circadian
rhythms is the idea that maybe when we
eat could have importance and supporting
this our studies that have been
conducted in mice that have shown that
mice with disrupted circadian clock for
ethnicity can result in increased risk
of cancer and metabolic diseases but the
important and key thing for this
emaciation for this study is the fact
that time restricted feeding in the mice
could risk that there are disrupted
rhythm and actually protects against
these diseases you can read about more
of the results from one of the studies
in this paper here
and in particular I want to highlight
that they did this without reducing the
calorie intake which is important for
what we get to the study setup and that
was also done and such in pandas lab and
he has a bit cooled this Akkadian code I
think it's good that I read a year ago
it's actually quite interesting if
you're interested in this topic I would
definitely recommend reading that anyway
now that we have some understanding of
why they wanted to do this study in the
first place what did they actually do so
as I said this was a human study and
they had 14 participants and they were
all healthy subjects 13 of them were men
and there was one female in the study
and the average age was 30 and so each
of them fasted for more than 14 hours a
day for 30 consecutive days and so if we
look at this diagram here the fasting
period actually took place during the
daytime so they would eat pretty much
when they wake up and eat again before
bed and then journalist fasting periods
they weren't also allowed to eat or
drink
and that included water so to understand
the biological impact of this
intermittent fasting the author's took
serum samples that they got from the
blood of the different subjects and they
did this before the 30-day fasting
periods they took another sample during
the fasting at the end of the fourth
week and then they took a final sample
one week after the fasting periods so
what the author said with these samples
is they looked at the proteins that were
present and then by taking them at these
different time points they could see how
different proteins changed over time and
whether they increased or decreased in
the amounts and then based on those
correlations they looked at the
literature to see if the changes were
either good or bad in respond to
different metabolic and other diseases
such as cancer say for example if let's
say protein X was really high in a tumor
and they saw that protein X went down
during the fasting period that would be
a benefit as opposed to a detrimental
impact of the fasting so what did they
see
so this is some of the data that they
could
I'm this plot basically shows by how
much different proteins either increased
or decreased from before the fasting to
during the fasting periods while
technically these are the genes that
include the proteins so the first one I
circled was a PP which is the amyloid
precursor protein which is associated
with Alzheimer's disease so they thought
that came down after the fasting periods
and another one I've highlighted as laps
1 which is thought to be an anti-cancer
gene
I've also circled NR 1 d1 which actually
includes one of the circadian clock
components which they saw gave up during
the fasting and I've also highlighted a
protein and falls in the insulin
response so I mean I could go through
each gene by gene and tell you what they
saw but I can't me both words basically
so I'll just generalized what they saw
and after from the first day fasting
they saw associated changes within the
protein that was protective against
cancer obesity diabetes and metabolic
syndromes and they also saw changes that
induced the increase of proteins
involved in DNA repair and the immune
system however I think these studies
have to be taken with quite a pinch of
salt because they are just associations
and that doesn't necessarily mean
causation or if it is necessarily
beneficial or detrimental and so besides
that there are other limitations said
the author acknowledged that's just the
fact that they only did this for 30 days
and maybe beta trial time periods it
also wasn't a parallel control group but
there was no fasting and in addition I
mean this was a very small sample size
there's only 14 of them and there was a
lot more men than female and they only
looked at their serum changes and there
are other different factors that they
should consider and look at as well and
as I said at the start there are also
different methods of intermittent
fasting and it would be pretty
interesting to compare two of them
together in particular because the 14
hour method that they chose here is
actually quite stringent and I think
stringent was the right word but they
also can have more time in it seems
quite tough um anyway they did see
pretty to make changes and I think that
goes to show you that there definitely
is something going on with time
restricted intermittent fasting and I
think it'd be really interesting to see
more research when it comes out and so
as always I hope you've learnt something
and thanks for listening